katie is with us
in fayetteville arkansas hi katie
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
um i'm actually like hiding in a closet
just to ask you this question because
i've got
in-laws in the house my question
pertaining to them
um but anyway i'm 24
and my husband is 28 and we're a
newlywed couple and we just bought our
first house in arkansas
our family is from california and a
month ago my husband's parents
decided to move to arkansas to be close
to us and
for the lower cost of living and so we
actually invited them to
temporarily stay with us in our new
house
under the expectation that they'd take a
couple of months to find their own place
and that my father-in-law will
find a job over here because he's
actually been on unemployment
for a year now which actually just ended
um but it seems like the problem is my
father-in-law
isn't really motivated to find a job and
move out
um he hasn't applied to anything and uh
he gives like every excuse to delay
applying
um and it just seems like they're
waiting around for
his social security to kick in with when
he turns 62
which is still over a year away and
they're in debt
and they have no retirement plan and we
spend a lot so my question is
how can my husband and i motivate them
to move out or at least give us a plan
for when they will move out so we can
enjoy our space and our new home as a
newly married couple
and you don't have to make phone calls
hiding in a closet in a home you own
yeah that would be a neat thing
that that word picture right there kind
of says it all doesn't it
yep yeah okay how long you guys been
married
uh less than a year okay all right
um well this is a um
highly emotional very difficult process
that you've gotten yourself into as you
can imagine
and my suggestion to you is is that you
don't say a word
to them that he does all the talking
their son the thing is my husband will
say like
your husband needs to grow a backbone
if not you can run down to walmart you
can buy them on all three he needs a
backbone
if you try to handle this you're going
to be the wicked witch of the west for
the next 42 years in this family
yeah it's not gonna work
you do not have the emotional footing to
throw his parents out
only he does
your problem is not your in-laws your
problem is your pa
your husband
he won't deal with this so you called me
did i miss something he would be on the
phone with me right now if he could
um but the thing is it whatever he says
to his parents
it doesn't land um because they will
guilt-trip them and we were the ones who
invited them to live here
i understand that i understand that but
it'll land
if it sounds very clear and it's very
loving and very very firm
and he needs to lower his voice an
octave when he's doing it
and very very calm
and say mom and dad this isn't working
we thought we were helping you you're
driving us crazy
we love you you have 30 days
november the 1st you guys need to be
living somewhere else
now let's figure out together how we can
cause that to happen
because you will not be living here
after november first this has gone on
too long
it doesn't seem to have an end to it and
i love you more than life itself
you cannot live in my house i've been
married one year
i need my space
now let me tell you what's going to
happen okay okay
your lazy butt father-in-law is going to
get angry
and your husband's going to have to
smile and say dad
i love you and november the 1st
you're not going to be living here
anymore
and then the mother-in-law is going to
chime in and she's a travel agent for
guilt trips
and you're going to have to bite your
little tongue and blood is going to run
down the back of your throat and you're
not going to say a freaking word
but your husband is going to man up and
handle this messy maid
if it doesn't go down that way that's
the least
messy you can do okay option number two
is
you get involved and you are the wicked
witch of the west for the next 42 years
you're the evil daughter that stole your
your mother-in-law's son away and then
you wouldn't let them live
for free in perpetuation and you're just
a jerk
and because they can't blame him because
he's there so they'll have to blame you
if you open your freaking mouth and say
one word that's what's going to happen
now can you tell i've been here before
so yeah the uh the second thing that's
gonna happen is
you're gonna do nothing and you're gonna
sit here and get progressively miserable
and three years from now you're gonna
still be sitting in your closet talking
on the phone
and that will be your fault not theirs
because you didn't deal with this you
have got to deal with this
you know exactly what needs to occur so
does he
no one wants to face it and so basically
these guys have become emotional bullies
to y'all
they're holding you at bay because
you're scared of their reaction
is that right that is right
um so you know hubby
hubby hubby hubby backbone bubba
backbone
you got to stand up time to be the man
and go you know mom and dad we thought
we were being a blessing but
gosh it's just not working you're
driving us nuts we don't even see you
out here looking for a job
we can't figure out what's going on so
i'm just going to go ahead and give you
a deadline and then we'll work together
and help you get there
if i can help you get a job fine if i
can do some other stuff fine i'll help
you move your stuff
i mean we're gonna we're gonna we love
you we're not trying to be mean to you
but we do not take you to raise and we
cannot you cannot be here anymore
he's just gonna have to say all those
things and he probably ought to say i'm
like tonight
should i be in the room or you can keep
your mouth shut
okay some people can keep their mouth
shut in these situations and others
can't
because when the stress comes up and the
uh the confrontation hits the air
people want to let the let the uh let
the air out by
cracking a joke or by interjecting and
trying to say something nice because it
feels like it's mean
or something like that and if you want
to if you're the nice person
that you and and you can't keep your
mouth shut then stay out of the room
but this is not this is not unkind we're
not being
mean we're not angry
we're just gentle strong and saying out
loud
that this has got to change and i love
you mom and dad
and the reason we let you move in here
in the first place is we love you
but this idea that we're going to live
together for three or four years
ain't happening and it appears there's
no end to this
so we're going to put a deadline on it
okay it feels like a lot of conflict
doesn't it
yeah it does and the thing is they're
not terrible no they're not bad
people they're just lazy
and they've been saying like oh once we
move to arkansas
um i'll apply for a job or like once uh
this happens i'll apply for the job kick
the can down the road
so now once you're homeless you can
apply for a job
because you're getting ready to be
homeless
or maybe you ought to apply a job now so
that you're not homeless that might be
even a better plan
i'm being sarcastic okay but these are
not bad people but
no one tells them no
and that's how they've gotten away with
this crap
no everybody because they're such sweet
people they're what we call a lovable
slacker
we like them they're sweet but they
don't do squat
and they just they become a parasite
into your life
so if you want to pick up the book and
become an expert on this you can
it's by dr henry cloud it's called
boundaries
and it'll change your life and that way
you want to make phone calls
from the closet in your own home
the absurdity of that picture
illustrates how badly you have to deal
with this